the United States currently faces many
long-term policy challenges and each of
them is characterized by the common
denominator that we have to make hard
choices today in order to ensure
benefits for the future and that we're
not doing a very good job of addressing
these challenges one that's been in the
news a lot recently is climate change
where the increasing scientific evidence
is mounting suggesting that climate
change is going to have devastating
impacts on the American economy and the
way we live our lives yet we see very
little initiative to invest in costs
today in order to mitigate these future
damages similarly another area where
climate change comes into play is
disaster management we've recently seen
examples of terrible natural disasters
such as Hurricane Katrina and hurricane
sandy that have devastated coastal
regions of the United States and in each
of these cases the local governments and
the national governments did not take
ex-ante measures in order to mitigate
the disasters but rather just came in
after that they had caused their damage
outside of the domain of climate we also
see cases of public pensions in debt
where we have challenges facing the
long-term economic security and
financial health of the United States
with respect to the debt we have a lot
of entitlement obligations such as
Social Security and Medicare that are
not being addressed given the changing
demographics and aging nature of the
American population and governors
throughout the United States of both
political parties have basically
promised a great deal of pensions to
public sector employees as opposed to
increasing taxes in wages today and
there really is no good way to pay for
these things and each of these cases we
don't see very much mobilization on the
part of the political class to address
these long-term policymaking challenges
so one question that arises is who's to
blame for our failure to address these
long-term policymaking challenges now
the media always likes to denigrate the
political class and political elites as
it's very easy to say that politicians
are not doing a good job and the process
in Washington is broken however our
research has suggested that the American
voter is actually to blame for a lot of
these problems in the way that voters
incentivize politicians so I'll give you
two examples so one of our research
projects collected data on all the
disasters that had taken place since
1988 along with election returns and
government policy making in the disaster
domain and what we found is that voters
do a pretty good job of rewarding
politicians for disaster relief spending
but do a very poor job for rewarding
them for disaster preparation spending
and you can see how these electoral
patterns create bad incentives for
politicians to essentially not spend
money before a disaster takes place to
undergo efficient mechanisms in order to
mitigate risk but rather to simply send
in a very expensive cavalry after the
disaster has taken place and then get
the credit for solving the problem
another example we found is that voters
oftentimes they're not very forward
looking towards the future but instead
are really subject to the whims at the
moment so we found that the local
college football game outcomes a few
days before the election significantly
influenced how well the incumbents do
because they represent shocks to
well-being in mood so a win versus a
loss by the local college football team
increased an incumbents vote share by
about 1.6 percentage points suggesting
that voters are overly influenced by
their mood and not doing all that they
need to do to be effective Democratic
citizens
then the question arises of what we can
actually do to address this problem and
failure of long-term policy making one
issue is that the United States is
characterized by short terms at least
compared to many other advanced
democracies on the planet now the
problem with short terms is that even
though they increase accountability
between representatives and constituents
they make politicians very short-sighted
the analogy would be a CEO who's so
concerned with quarterly earnings that
they forget about long-term health of
their shareholders employees and other
key stakeholder groups now it's not
going to be easy to lengthen terms in
the United States so what else can we do
well the media I think can do a lot to
educate voters about what's important to
incentivize politicians properly in the
case of disasters we rarely see the
media for example cover preventive
solutions to disasters or actions that
the government is taken to mitigate ex
ante risk but we oftentimes see young
great images of governors and presidents
kind of flying to disaster prone areas
and covering all the relief that gets
done and it's this kind of media
coverage that leads to bad attributions
and prevents the electorate from holding
the government accountable for the right
things I think one other problem in the
United States has been a recent
phenomenon is that the campaign cycles
are just too long we are in this period
of the permanent campaign so the 2014
midterm elections haven't even happened
yet yet the media is devoting extensive
coverage to the 2016 presidential
election and the problem with this is
that politicians know they have only a
few months to get policy done before
they have to go and start dealing with
the issue of the election once again and
this again makes people short term
minded if they're going to be evaluated
very soon after they come into office so
basically if the media focus less on the
next campaign and more on the policy
challenges facing the country then
voters might do a better job
you